in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape with me in
studio is Professor Stephan one close
he's head of the institute of medical
and human genetics at the charity
hospital in berlin hello welcome to the
show you're not doing research you're
offering kind of an outpatient clinic
for genetic counseling what kind of
patients to come to your outpatient
clinic basically patients whether it's a
suspicion for a genetic disease and that
means that there is a certain conditions
where the genetic component of this
disease is the major one and you're
looking for genetic disorders or do you
give device and what what to do about
this well we test for genetic diseases
and then we also give advice what to do
and how to treat them but we don't treat
them ourselves we are mainly a
diagnostic facility and let's talk about
humors we know that breast cancer and
colon cancer has a strong genetic course
in some cases what about other malignant
diseases are the other tumors which are
bound to genetic disorders there are a
number of other tumors that I also have
major genetic causes for example stomach
or of the thyroid gland but these are
much smaller in the percentage than
compared to president and colon cancer
for example and can you test for those
kind of genes in the other malignant
diseases or just for breast cancer and
colon cancer well the breast cancer and
colon cancer is the most common one and
there the test system is the most
efficient one for the other hereditary
we can also test but it's more
complicated and as I said it's it's a
very small and rare disease group okay
in the difference of patient test
positive for breast cancer does it mean
that she and gets this cancer in one
hundred percent chances or are there any
ways out of it no it doesn't mean that
they get er than one hundred percent
just dramatically increases your risk up
to about eighty percent from normally
ten percent so there is a dramatic
increase but not all of them will get
cancer okay sometimes cancer seems to
run in families even if there's no
strong genetic disease underlying it and
how do you explain this finding we see
that quite often that we have multiple
different kinds of cancers and families
and there is certainly a genetic
component in there but at the moment for
the great majority of these families we
cannot really test for that because
they're probably multiple factors many
genes that contribute to that and the
problem with testing positive for some
certain kind of tense cancer is that you
can't really change your genome so what
do you do for instance if you would test
positive for colon cancer well you can
do additional testing for example via
endoscopy and others and and without you
can detect cancer in a very early state
and you will be able to remove it for
example so that will definitely help and
if you would not know that you would not
do that additional testing so there are
real therapeutic consequences you can
derive from this kind of genetic testing
or they are definitely therapeutic
contact lenses not in the way that you
can eliminate it but you can test for it
and by that you can try to remove the
tumor before it gets really big and
cannot be removed any more so before it
gets malignant and maybe kills you you
can just move it in a very early stage
exactly yes okay we got a view a
question from New Zealand our viewer
rosie and sutherland wants to know that
her parents suffer from high blood
pressure hypertension and she as a
patient suffers as well from high blood
pressure is this a genetic cause well
high blood pressure has a high genetic
component and if both of her parents
suffer from that conditioned and the
likelihood that she has a two is quite
high but there are no simple genetic
tests for it because they're probably
many different factors and genes that
contribute to it so it's not just one
gene that codes for a bloody high blood
pressure exactly there are several ones
and we can test for that at the mall
and how high is the risk that regime
passes and the high blood pressure on to
her daughter well I would think that
also depends on the father of her
daughter if he has a high blood pressure
to than the risk is relatively high if
he doesn't then it sort of mixes up
again and that certainly reduces it
generally spoken how should someone
react when there's certain diseases run
in the family should I go and see my GP
and talk with him about it or should I
go and see a geneticist well the
geneticist is not a GP and I think first
people should talk to their doctor and
tell them about what they think about
the family and if this occurs more
frequently or or not and then I think
the GP can decide and maybe sent the the
family or the patient to a geneticist to
the specialist and many people start to
think about their genes when they're
pregnant and they're expecting a baby
because of passing on the genes and
would you advise every single pregnant
women to go and talk it was a
gynecologist about genetic disorder or
even see a geneticist well she would she
should totally shut and certainly talk
with her gynecologist about the
possibility of genetic testing and if
genetic testing is performed then she
should talk to someone who knows how
they work and who can explain it over to
her that can be the gynecologist but can
also be a geneticist and it's not all
about genetic diseases for the newborn
baby we got a viewer question from
norway sad a suit I Jesco from Norway
had unfortunately two miscarriages in
her past and now she wants to know if
she's at a high risk for a third
miscarriage and if this could be genetic
well generally miscarriages are quite
common so that is certainly something
that happens quite often but they are
genetic causes for that and it lets say
if it happens another time a third time
then one should certainly think about it
and then she should ask her doctor and
they can be genetic tests that can be
performed to test before an increased
risk and you as an expert what do you
think about those genetic home test kits
we got a view a question from Mexico
padilha will answer guevara she learned
about a genetic
test kit for at home just put some
saliva on a stick and send it to a lap
and then see what's in your genes is it
a proper way to deal with genetic
illnesses well we don't think it's a
proper way because for any of these
testings you should have some sort of
counseling people should explain you
what the test is for and what can be
expected and that is not done with these
online tests and the other thing is yeah
what to do about genetic testing and
what the result and do you think it's
it's wise for say a 20-year old to know
that he or she will get Alzheimer when
she's 80 well that's the big problem of
genetic testing and especially of
testing healthy people is that everyone
has to decide on his or her own whether
he or she wants to really wants to know
it that's a very personal decision that
can only be made if you have all the
information and then really can decide
on your own it's not something that I
can advise and that way so it's not only
a medical question it's a little bit of
philosophical question well it's a very
personal question thank you dr. Montrose
thanks for being in this video welcome
you